as fine a general or political leader as
I'm sure you are I'm here to tell you
the applying Total War Three Kingdoms
all wrong
okay wrong maybe a little too far we're
not talking dong zhuo inviting diao chan
to court levels of error but since I
started approaching my total war
campaigns a little differently I've been
finding more enjoyment in the romances
blend of history myth and legend
Balto award is a fantastic job in
allowing you to choose your leaders
alliances and generals and evolving
those stories as a campaign progresses
I prefer looking at the game's
proceedings from a lower angle
specifically from the point of view of
the common soldier looking up at these
legends of politics and battle surely
obey and South I'll make fantastic
leaders but the world of China looks
completely different through their eyes
compared to how it looks through the
lens of a commoner living in the period
of the Three Kingdoms
what makes this period of history so
interesting is the sheer number of
larger-than-life characters and
personalities that occupied that era and
the incredible stories that became
associated with them looking back at
these stories now the lines between what
is stone-cold fact and what is hearsay
and fiction can become somewhat blurred
what really happened what was
embellished by people in historical
records and what further made its way
into myths since the writing of the
Romance of the Three Kingdoms
well we may never know for sure if ja ho
Doon yanked out the arrow that blinded
him in one eye and ate it off the
arrowhead this is undeniably the
larger-than-life story he's most famous
for and true or not it's part of his
history now
[Applause]
when you pick one of the characters at
the start of a campaign Creative
Assembly has built the game so that
follows with the intention that you're
playing as that character so whether it
be through the eyes of Liu Bei Marv Tang
or whoever else you pick the intention
is that you're ruling their world and
fighting their battles part of me feels
a certain guilt for suggesting that you
as the player should alter your view
away from these characters and their
perspectives especially since such care
and attention was put into them after
playing a lot of the game and talking to
some of the writers I can tell that
their research was meticulous it's
impressive to see such care and
attention put into re creating these
individuals in such a heartfelt and
authentic way especially hundreds of
years after they did these legendary
actions but my intention isn't to take
anything away from both of writings of
the romance novels or how each character
is portrayed in the game but perhaps
expand on it in my own small potentially
backwards way I would argue that a thing
that these people are most famous for
historically are the actions that were
potentially a little embellished the
moments that made them seem like
superheroes of their own time so yeah I
suppose in a way I'm comparing one of
the most far-reaching and culturally
important fictional words the last
millennium to comic book series
[Music]
now while visiting creative assembly I
talked to Total War three kingdoms
writer Pete Stewart about taking a
different perspective when looking at
the progression of a campaign and how
this viewpoint may differ from previous
total war titles it's an interesting
point to say that yeah like if they're
super powerful and knocking people this
away and you have these special
abilities then it could be yeah that's
the creating myth as you go in always
because there's never been a total war
that's been so focused on on characters
in this way that we've had games in the
past that focused on a single character
and their defining moment in history but
but there's loads of amazing
larger-than-life characters in three
kingdoms and it's not only it's finding
their voice so I said before through
like the for the text but also bringing
them to life in a way like in imagining
what they might do and what they might
say like the conversation system that
you heard in battle for instance like
what they talk like that is this
accurate enough and you have to take
those liberties but also the be as
authentic as you can at the same time
it's like maybe you read quotes from
historians and historical figures for
these really cool sharp things that we
can never think of in the cuff off the
cuff like we do now like they did say
all these things they did do all these
deeds just not perhaps as quite as
explosively as they did so so yeah I
think in a way what meaning is obvious I
think is because that we can while also
making them mad super heroes yet your
words not mine but think about the
characters from the Three Kingdoms in
the novels in movies in video games
these individuals are always portrayed
as having godlike fighting abilities
paler strength incredible speed or
superior intellect
these old traits synonymous with people
like Guan Yu Lee oh boo aw sow sow and
while history is full of embellished
stories the people that would most
likely believe these tales and share
them with friends and family or swap
stories in taverns or around fires after
a battle are the members of the soldiery
or peasantry that would actually be
living and fighting through the time
period while guan yu or lubu may not
have actually been able to match ten
thousand soldiers or Cleave [ __ ] of
warriors of the swing of their glaive
the stories them doing so and their
presence in the battlefield could have
had the same morale boosting effect in
the real battles that took place with
each soldier fighting that
much harder while the God of War or
flying general is fighting alongside
them and it's from this perspective that
I think total war three kingdoms really
shines now at the end of the day the
Total War franchise is a series of
sandbox games based in history sure it
has historically accurate aspects to it
but by virtue of you controlling an
empire dynasty or country by
manipulating variables in a way that
wouldn't have been possible back then it
simply cannot remain completely true to
history sure it'd be more realistic to
depict the characters in three kingdoms
as more human figures but at the same
time it'd be a less authentic
representation of who they were at the
time and more importantly the impact
that they had on those around them
no matter the source these myths and
legends are now part of history and
watching them achieved the impossible as
my commanders Vanguard's and strategists
has been a wonderful way to see that
part of admittedly embellished history
come to life embellished a lot much of
the history we know now suffers from
having some form of bias or has been a
version of events as quote written by
the victors but what we have here with
three kingdoms is a game that not only
presents people and actions as they were
but also how they should be remembered
all the while doing a fantastic job of
retaining some of the culture and spirit
of these people that existed at the time
which in my mind is just as important as
ever thanks for listening to me talk
nonsense about one of my favorite games
of the year so far let me know what you
think in the comments below whether
you're fully sold on the romance style
of total war or prefer the less esoteric
records mode and tweet me at a regular
Dave with your pick for best boy in
total war three kingdoms
it's obviously Leo Bay though
you
[Music]